*epic music*
Heeeyyyyy YouTube
*Music intenseifies*
Tic
Tok
Where the FUCK is my diamond play button?
It's been 84 YEARS!
*satan of roast*
Yeah that's right YouTube, I said it!
You think I'm scaaaared??
Like all the other pussy ass YouTubers???
Like Markiplier,
Jacksepticeye,
Or CinnamonToastKen
[Ken]: OH SHIT WHADDUP?
[Felix]: Oh shit it's yo boy!!!
[Ken]: YO BOY
[Felix]: YEAAAH
[Ken]: IT'S YO BOY
[Felix]: WELCOME TO THE ROAST!!
*warrior scream*
[Felix]: BIIITCH
[Ken]: BITCH
[Felix]: PREPARED TO GET INFIL--
*pewds dictonary breaks..*
[Felix]: What's the word?
[Felix]: INFILTRATE!
[Felix]: PREPARE TO GET......
*processing...*
[Felix]: ANNIHILATED!!
*screams of roasters.. or roosters. you choose*
*dramatic music*
[Felix]: Hey Youtube!
[Felix]: What a great stream service you got there with YouTube Red!
[Felix]: Too bad Netflix has already been a thing!
[Ken]: OOOOOOHHHH NETFLIX IS ALREADY A THING, BITCH
[Ken]: OHHHH
[Felix]: Please still fund YouTube Scare PewDiePie
[Felix]: YouTube Red
[Ken]: But you ain't SHIT
[Ken]: BIIIIITCH
[Felix]: THAT'S RIGHT YOU AIN'T SHIT THOUGH
[Felix]: BIIIITCH
[Felix]: And how about that YouTube streaming service???
[Felix]: Good thing Twitch isn't already a thing
*Kens heart attack begins*
[Ken]: Oh, oh God!
[Ken]: The truth, he speaks the TRUTH!
[Felix]: I speak the truth
[Ken]: JESUS! OH JESUS!
[Ken]: Aah!
[Ken]: Tell 'em wassup , tell 'em wassup
[Felix]: Hey YouTube!
[Felix]: That comment system is fucking awesome!
[Felix]: Just kidding, IT SUCKS!
[Ken]: OHHHHH THE POWER OF PEWDS COMPELS YOU!
[Ken]: THE POWER OF PEWDS COMPELS YOU
[Felix]: IT COMPELS YOU!
[Ken]: WOOOOOH!
[Felix]: ARE YOU COMPELLED?
[Felix]: ARE YOU COMPELLED????
[Ken]: I FEEL THE HOLY SPIRIT OF PEWDIEPIE!
[Felix]: YEAAAH
WOOOOOOH WOOOOH
[Felix]: Ohh, is it hot in here??
[Felix]: OR IS YOUR ASS JUST GETTING ROASTED?
[Ken]: RUBBER DUCKS, BIITCH!
[Felix]: RUBBER DUCK!
[Felix]: Wait, what the fuck..
[Felix]: Hey YouTube!
[Felix]: Google+ was a great idea (no it wasn't)
[Felix]: Too bad FACEBOOK ISN'T ALREADY A THING!
[Ken]: OHHHHH CLOWN ART
[Felix]: OH!
[Ken]: OHHHHHHHHHHHH!
[Ken]: OHHHHH!
[Felix]: OH!
[Ken]: OHHH!
[Ken]: Leave a like :)
[Felix]: Hey YouTube!
[Felix]: I'm proud of you
[Felix]: You made so much money throughout the year
[Felix]: OHH WAIT YOU DIDN'T MAKE SHIT!
[Felix]: OOOOOOHHH
*Ken dies*
*giggle*
[Felix]: HOW BOUT YOU TAKE MORE THAN 45% MORE OF OUR INCOME?
[Ken]: Wait......
[Ken]: What?
.....?
[Felix]: Yeah yo- they take 45%
*Processing information..*
*relieze's*
[Ken]: 45 percent?
[Felix]: 45 percent.
(maybe 45% can be our always)
*laughing*
[Felix]: YOUTUBE GAMING?
[Felix]: MORE LIKE YOUTUBE LAMING!
[Ken]: OHOOHOHOH
[Felix]: Up top
[Ken]: HOHO
*fail highfive*
[Ken]: HOH
*awkward silence*
[Felix]: ...You missed on purpose right?
*laughing*
[Felix]: YouTube Red
*zooms in dramaticly on Pewds and Ken's face*
[Felix]: More like
[Felix]: You-
[Felix]: YouT-
[Felix]: YouPorn!
[Felix]: Uhm, RedTube
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
[Felix]: Hey YouTube!
[Felix]: Your search algorithm is so corrupt
[Felix]: IT MAKES VLADIMIR PUTIN LOOK LIKE JEZUS!
[Ken]: OOOOHHH JEZUS
[Felix]: DO WE NEED ANOTHER LEAFY?
[Ken]: WOOO!
[Felix]: DO WE NEED ANOTHER CLICKBAIT PIECE OF SHIT??
*Pewds dancing while Ken squishs teh  rubber duck on himself*
*doorbell*
[Felix]: Who the fuck is dat..?
[Ken]: I think its me....
da fuck?
[Felix]: I'll check it out!
*amazing sound*
*dundundun*